the rossi has flown its last mission on
prime video sci-fi hit the expanse does
marco recapture medina station or to
holden and the crew find a way to thwart
him let's explore what happened in the
final episode of the expanse babylon's
ashes
in the previous episode of the expanse
proud belter kamina drummer agrees to
join forces with unn secretary general
christian avasarala and the inner
planets while drummer is no friend to
the earthers she also isn't an ally of
marco so when naomi nagada shows up to
convince her to speak to a vasarala
drummer agrees begrudgingly
acknowledging that marco now poses a
bigger threat than the inners she
despises at the beginning of babylon's
ashes drummer meets with a coalition
from earth and mars which also includes
james holden and bobby draper
representing the rossi marco's free navy
is flying toward medina station inside
the ring and the alliance needs to stop
him before he reaches the ring gate if
he makes it there he'll be able to hide
behind the rail guns that were mounted
on medina in control of our colonies and
a thousand systems
dictating the fate of our species for a
generation the free navy is split into
three battle groups and the unn and
martians plan to go after the groups
with the biggest warships drummer and
her ragtap belter fleets are assigned to
attack the smaller group which consists
mostly of cargo ships meanwhile the
rossi and strike team led by bobby plan
to take control of the rail guns at
medina station so they can turn them on
marco if he gets past the inner forces
unn secretary general of asarala hardly
believes that the plan will work you're
such an optimist
it's a miracle you've lived this long
the unn battle group is heading toward
the free navy one of azerala is informed
that the intelligence obtained by the
rossi has revealed the location of
marco's ship the pella drummer hears the
news that the unn fleet is planning to
engage the pella over her radio and
looks stoic as she turns her attention
to the battle group her fleet is
targeting
the frigate is the main threat if we
kill it first we can make the rest
surrender or run unnn1 hits the pillow
with their torpedoes and then falls back
but ivasarala notices the pellet doesn't
return fire and the other free navy
ships aren't falling back to protect it
which indicates marco isn't on the ship
they are understandably baffled by this
development at the same time drummer's
fleet engages the freighter and the free
navy battle group they're fighting as
her fleet fires the freighter's cargo
drops away revealing the pella marco
fires on drummer and a fierce gun battle
follows the action briefly knocks
drummer out and she awakens to find a
large hole in the side of her ship she's
informed that her torpedoes are gone two
of her fleets ships are lost and the
pella is heading back toward them
drummer instructs her fleet to disengage
and prepares to drive her ship into the
pella in a last-ditch effort to stop it
she is not at all afraid to sacrifice
herself for the cause leave the pellet
to me
however her ally walker beats her to it
the impact in its aftermath severely
damages the pella and marco's advisor
rosenfeld perishes in the aftermath of
the battle drummer disengages
recognizing that there's nothing else
she can do she will have to wait for the
crew of the rossi to carry through with
their portion of the plan
as the rossi burns toward medina station
the members of the strikeforce are
ejected from giambattissa an ice hauler
the rossi is hit and clarissa mao goes
to fix the damage but is knocked out as
medina's railguns fire on the ship when
they reach the vicinity of medina the
strike team exits their pods the rossi
moves out of range of the railguns and
naomi checks on clarissa who reveals
she's fixed the damage i didn't use my
mods
just a ratchet strap and some elbow
grease
meanwhile the strike team drops through
space in a barrage of bullets when they
land on medina they take fire from the
ground and air bobby calls the rossi for
air support but the ship can't help as
long as the railguns are still in play
bobby orders everyone to fall back as
she advances becoming an assault force
of one
she takes heavy fire but manages to take
out the railgun's control center just
when it looks like she won't make it
amos arrives to cover her they're both
pinned down but the rossi appears to
provide the air support they desperately
need as the battle ends bobby explains
she had no choice but to disable the
railguns it was better to knock them out
than enable the free navy to keep
operating them
on the pella which is still speeding
toward the ring marco gets a message
from admiral duarte one of the
masterminds behind the rogue martian
faction that traded martian technology
for the proto-molecule sample and
scientist paolo quartazar in the fifth
season throughout season six the
beginning of each episode shows a
snippet of what's happening on the ring
planet laconia where duarte settled but
it isn't until episode 4 that we meet
him duarte attends a funeral of young
kara's brother and as he speaks to her
about the loss kotazar informs duarte
that he has finally managed to
communicate with the dormant alien
spacecraft hovering above the planet at
the beginning of babylon's ashes duarte
looks up at the sky smugly seemingly
indicating he's confident that he's now
harnessed the proto-molecule's power as
duarte's message to marco makes clear
that means he no longer feels he owes
marco or the pre-navy anything including
the laconian weapons marco requested for
the battle the free navy is in the
middle of waging duarte's message is a
massive kiss off as he not only denies
marco the weapons but also warns him to
stay away from the laconian system
entirely as duarte tells him you were a
useful distraction but i have gods to
kill yikes unfortunately since this is
the show's final episode we won't get to
see how duarte's quest turns out knowing
how producers think these days it's
totally possible that they'll decide to
expand on the expanse and explore this
storyline further
while marco's relationship with laconia
has been severed he's still about to win
the war against the inners and is
already making plans for when he
recaptures medina station only the rossi
stands in his way the crew tosses around
ideas to stop him even though they know
they don't have enough firepower to do
so however naomi comes up with an idea
that could end marco permanently we
might be able to trigger the ring
entities
earlier in the season holden notices
that some ships disappear without a
trace as they pass through the ring in
season five he tells fred johnson that
whenever he goes through the ring he
feels angry entities lurking inside he
believes these are the aliens that
created the rings and took out the
civilization that made the
proto-molecule holden thinks humanity is
waking up these malevolent beings by
going through the rings now in the
penultimate episode of season six
holding's investigation into the ships
that vanished in the rings leads him to
season 4's dr okoye who tells him that
the disappearances are preceded or might
be triggered by a mass energy threshold
naomi realizes they can use this
information against marco and the free
navy if they can push as much mass as
possible through the ring at exactly the
right time they can reach the energy
threshold to trigger the ring entities
the ring entities will then lash out at
marco's ship putting a stop to him once
and for all
naomi's plan works perfectly and though
she deeply mourns the loss of her and
marco's son phillip whom she believes
was on the pillow with his father she
and the crew of the rossi managed to
bring marco and the pre-navy to an end
this leaves the leaders of earth and
mars and those in the belt who aren't
loyal to marco to negotiate a truce
along with avasarala and mars as prime
minister drummer represents the belters
and the talks holden is also at the
table as the one earther who is a friend
to all sides all parties agree they need
to form a transport union to control
trade to the ring colonies but the
belters want control as they believe
earth and mars will eventually go back
to their old oppressive ways i will not
be reasoned back into my place
belt is a promise a future so long as it
remains convenient none of the factions
will budge so holden points out that if
they can't find a way to trust each
other now they never will this gives
vassarala an idea the transport union
could be an independent agency with
holden someone earth mars and the
belters trust as its leader holden is
surprised by the idea but ultimately
says he's open to it if he can have
certain assurances
the scene cuts to the ceremonial medina
station announcing the formation of the
transport union and holden as its
president holden makes a speech
expressing his pride in being the first
head of the new organization as of
asarala and drummer the union's vice
president stand on either side of him
the teleprompter indicates his speech is
coming to an end and a basarala moves to
congratulate him but holden keeps
talking there's an audible gasp as he
resigns as a leader of the transport
union and introduces drummer as the new
president to the joy of the belter's
present the future of the belt has to
speak with a belter's voice and in that
spirit i'm proud to introduce the new
president of the transport union to
meena drummer
drummer steps up to the podium to answer
questions as holden walks away and is
confronted by a furious of asarala
she accuses him of negotiating in bad
faith and says she'll undo his actions
but he begs her not to convinced he's
done the right thing ultimately
ivasarala backs down and smiles as the
pair shake hands
later holden and the crew were back on
the rossi where bobby has joined them as
their new pilot when they're alone
holden acknowledges to naomi that he
made a lot of people angry by stepping
down from the transport union she
reassures him he did the right thing and
gives a speech about helping people and
small actions making big impacts you
followed your conscience in the hope
that others would follow theirs
as she talks the story flashes back to
the pella before it entered the ring
marco had just given a rousing speech to
the crew's cheers but philip isn't
enthralled like the others his brief
exposure to his mother's perspective in
season 5 opens his eyes to just how
manipulative marco can be and throughout
the sixth season philip becomes
increasingly convinced marco may not be
doing the right thing the last straw
comes when marco dismisses rosenfeld's
death and indicates he and philip made a
choice to be in their current situation
of course philip had no choice so as
marco distracts his minions with pretty
words philip takes a ship and flies away
from the pela and his father most
tellingly when designating himself as a
ship's owner he types in the name philip
nagata taking naomi's last name instead
of marcos on the rossi holden starts
brainstorming their next moves but naomi
interrupts him asking him to take a
breath before they begin a new adventure
this brings the show to a quiet end
that's still bursting with possibilities
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]